foreign
[Music]
crime daily leaked documents reveal a
shocking supreme court news never before
in modern history has an internal draft
been leaked to the public
while the justices were still
deciding the case could Roe versus Wade
be overturned but first Amber heard's
team calls its first witness to the
stand I diagnosed misheard with
post-traumatic stress disorder plus
Johnny Depp's team rests its case after
expert testimony Mr Depp suffered lost
earnings of approximately 40 million
dollars and later how did the Washington
Post op-ed affect Depp's reputation the
public thinks he's damaged we are live
in Fairfax Virginia for day 13 of the
contentious case lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ER Johnny Depp rests his case in the
multi-million dollar defamation case
against ex-wife Amber Heard lawn crime
Network's Jesse Weber was inside the
courtroom for Depp's Final witness and
Jesse you saw the first witness called
by hers defense team
that's right Brian today was about the
end of one case the start of another in
a major development that happened
outside the presence of the jury in fact
the day started off with continued
testimony of Amber heard's nurse Aaron
fellati who talked about some of the
mental and physical conditions she
observed of her during her relationship
with Depp and from there we moved to the
testimony of forensic accountant Michael
Spindler who estimated that Depp
suffered lost earnings of 40 million
dollars after 2018 that's the year that
the Washington Post article was
published and then after Spindler Johnny
Depp officially rested his case but the
drama didn't stop there because herd's
team argued a motion to strike basically
trying to dismiss the case but that was
ultimately denied well with at least
respect to two of the statements in the
article the third statement at issue the
judge said that she's going to review
later on because we may learn that her
didn't even write it and now the first
witness to testify as you said for Amber
Heard was clinical and forensic
psychologist Dr Dawn Hughes and she
basically explained that a victim of
domestic violence can act out and behave
in all the ways that Amber Heard has
been been accused of Behaving including
yelling physically fighting back and in
fact Dr Hughes examined herd and this
was her conclusion
Ms heard's report intimate partner
violence and the records that I reviewed
is consistent with what we know in the
field about intimate partner violence
characterized by physical violence
psychological aggression sexual violence
coercive control and surveillance
behaviors I miss her demonstrated very
clear psychological and traumatic
effects or the exacerbation of Trauma
from those statements that Mr debt made
through his attorney there were three
statements that we evaluated to see how
they affected her emotionally and
psychologically and it was in my
determination that they did
and did you arrive at any diagnostic
conclusions yes I did and what were
those I diagnosed misheard with
post-traumatic stress disorder in order
to have a to meet criteria for
post-traumatic stress disorder you have
to have an actual cause it's one of the
few diagnoses diagnostic entities that
we have to have a cause for and the
cause was the intimate partner violence
by Mr Depp that was the what was pushing
the symptoms that was what's related to
the intrusive phenomena that was related
to her avoidance that was elated to her
differences in her mood that was related
to her avoidance efforts so it was the
the cause was the intimate partner
violence by Mr debt
now that isn't that that is in direct
contrast to the testimony of Dr Curry
who testified for Johnny Depp's side so
this is just more conflicting and
complicating testimony for the jury to
ultimately sort out Brian
all right Jesse before we get into Dr
hughes's testimony who I won't confuse
for Dr Curry how did the depth team
finish off their case did they end on a
strong note
yeah I mean what they did was try to tie
it all together by saying at the end of
the day this is what happened to Johnny
Depp after the 2018 Washington Post
article he lost 40 million dollars he
lost the potential earnings of 40
million dollars he lost Pirates of the
Caribbean six his reputation has never
been the same that was one of the
weaknesses in his case when it first
started off and I think they really tied
it together towards the end now would I
have preferred maybe to see Johnny deppy
the last witness and put a bow on it
sure but at the end of the day they did
everything they could all right now
Jesse Dr Hughes uh on Tuesday only did
her direct and she took issues you said
with doctors Curry's interpretation did
that direct dismantle Dr Curry's
findings in your opinion
you have two conflicting experts that's
the problem you have two conflicting
experts and that you see that in a lot
of different cases at the end of the day
it's going to be up to the jury to
determine who's more credible and when
you have this it's a tough decision
because both are very very well
qualified and both spoke very well so
it's a tough decision for the jury but
direct contrast from what we heard from
depth side now Jesse I'm curious that's
what you think about this for the first
time I started to see emotion come from
Amber Heard throughout the testimony
what was your reaction to that and did
the jury react in any way either
so I didn't see the jury really looking
too much at Amber Heard and you know
what's interesting about watching her is
the testimony of Dr Hughes were said you
can have somebody who's stoic does not
show motion much emotion on the outside
but then is filled with emotion on the
inside I will tell you aside from Amber
Heard looking at the different people in
the gallery when Dr Hughes was
testifying my guess is they were mostly
Johnny Depp supporters because I saw a
number of people shaking their heads
Whispering that was a gallery filled
with mostly it seemed to be Johnny Depp
supporters so it's going to be very
interesting to see how her testimony
continues and what everyone makes of it
all right Jesse hold on tight we'll be
right back with you for more inside uh
look at this case thank you so much for
it still ahead on Law and crime daily or
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard coverage
continues here expert witness testimony
about Depp's Financial loss following
the release of the 2018 op-ed but does
the witness hold up on Cross that's next
on Long crime daily
foreign
[Music]
continues now as X's Johnny Depp and
Amber Heard face off in a Virginia court
on Tuesday Deb's team called its Final
witness an expert who testified to
Depp's economic damages
I concluded that Mr Depp suffered lost
earnings of approximately 40 million
dollars
how did you reach that conclusion
well there are really two main
components to that
the first relates to the loss of the
role of Captain Jack Sparrow and the
pirate Six film well the other main
component to this is taking a look at
all the other roles the non-franchise
films
so those
films Studio films Independent films and
endorsements that Mr Depp realizes and
and enjoys and you're assuming for the
purposes of your report that the damages
that you're testifying about were caused
by Amber's op-ed correct yes so you're
therefore not looking into whether
anything else that's happened with Mr
Depp's life or career could have caused
him economic damages correct
I believe that's generally correct yes
you're not looking at whether the
worsening performance at the box office
of Mr def's movies over time has caused
him the damages that you're testifying
about correct
correct and I'm not acknowledging any of
this being accurate I'm just saying that
that wasn't part of my calculations sure
I understand I just want to want to make
clear what you didn't look at
thank you
we're joined today by law and crime
legal analyst Kirk nurmi co-host Terry
Austin and correspondent Jesse Weber
live from the field Kirk if we're
looking at the numbers Spindler brought
those on Tuesday in court for sure but
do you think his research held up on
Cross
you know ultimately I do well this is
the best cross-examination I saw from
herd's Team throughout this entire trial
and they got out the reality that
there's a bit of speculation to it the
speculation he put forward seemed to be
based on sound reasoning there's never
going to be any exact tangibility to it
so if the jury believes that Mr Depp was
defamed I think this witness gave them
enough in order to get that 50 million
dollar figure that Mr Depp is requested
now Terry we heard Jazzy talk about he
would want uh Depp to be the last
witness but why do you think Deb's team
chose strategically to end with Spindler
as its Final witness and was that a good
call
well I don't think it was a bad call and
I don't disagree with Jesse I think
having Depp as the Final witness is a
great call but this is a forensic
accountant so Spindler was able to
explain to the jury just how Depp lost
that money because of herd's defamatory
statements he was able actually to
confirm Jack Wiggins testimony that
estimate at 40 million he talked about
the fact that the money was lost from
Pirate six he talked about the studio
and independent films so that was
important to end on a really scientific
note and don't forget they began with
Christy the sister she gave the soft
background ending with heart numbers not
a bad call yeah Jesse it seems like
Amber Heard has an uphill battle uphill
battle sorry after Deb's case but how do
you think she started off so far
she did a great job because she reset
the narrative and explained away all of
this objectionable or abusive behavior
that oh Amber Heard hit Johnny Depp
because she was in a reactive
self-defense manner this is what Dr
Hughes said Dr Hughes also testified
that this is somebody who would yell at
her partner this is somebody who might
not report violence that's inflicted
upon her because of the circumstances of
the situation she also talked about the
bystander effect maybe a number of
witnesses from Johnny Depp's side
wouldn't testify because they're not
going to testify against somebody that
employs them or that they like or that
they don't want to get involved in that
relationship and so explaining all of
this Behavior away which is what Johnny
Depp has been putting forward for the
past three weeks and explaining it away
in the first hour is a huge advantage to
Amber Heard as we are setting up for her
to take the stand and explain away
everything yeah absolutely paves the way
for Amber Heard to testify I think it's
smart to have an expert like this
testify to kind of lay the groundwork
and then we'll see Amber Heard hopefully
later this week Jesse as always thank
you for the Stellar reporting
thank you coming up on lawn crime daily
the Johnny Depp Amber Heard defamation
case gets analytical Deb's expert
witness breaks down the internet Trends
following the release of the infamous
op-ed
[Music]
welcome back we continue now with our
Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard coverage
analytics experts testify Depp's
reputation took a negative turn after
herd's 2016 abuse allegations and again
after the 2018 op-ed
you know as I mentioned earlier I wanted
to analyze the Q scores during this
snapshot of time I wanted to understand
what they were before during and after
the op-ed and what this tells me is his
positive Q score went from a 35 to a 29
and then his negative went from an 11 to
a 15. so what the Q scores is telling me
is the public perception of Mr Depp has
been damaged you know they they like him
less and they dislike him more
based on all of the analyzes that you
completed in this case what are your
final opinions about Mr Depp's
reputation over this period of time
yeah so my opinions are that you know Mr
Depp was not portrayed in a negative
connotation prior to the 2016
allegations of abuse
and then Mr Depp's image he was
portrayed in a negative connotation
after the 2016 allegations of abuse and
then more so after the 2018 Washington
Post op-ed uh and then the Q scores
represent that uh you know the public
thinks he's damaged they think uh less
likely of him his positive excuse Q
score has gone down and they don't like
him even more because his negative Q
score went from the 11 to the 15.
Terry important testimony but do you
think Deb's team got a little too
technical with a loss of reputation was
it perhaps an easier more powerful way
to do this line of testimony I guess
you know it was important I think Doug
benia is the internet analytics expert
and it was very tech technical but it
was necessary you know to have to prove
your case you have to show specifics and
I think that the jury probably missed
some of that they know from their own
experience whether or not Johnny Depp's
reputation went up or went down but what
they had to do was outline specifically
what was said and how that impacted his
reputation and they did that don't
forget they had the ACLU individual
Terence daughtery they had him up there
and he was able to connect the drafts of
the Washington Post off article directly
to Johnny Depp that was important and
then you know having the analytics
expert was also important having Richard
Marx he was the Hollywood expert he
talked about how media affects people
that was important and then finally it
ended on Spindler and he was the one who
talked about you know from an accounting
standpoint how it affected him
financially so all of that's important
it could be a little bit too technical
but I think the jury probably caught the
important parts of that testimony yeah
Kirk we're used to covering blood
spatter and and cell phone pinging here
the law and crime daily uh but do you
think this testimony of Google Trends
will be helpful in a similar way to this
case
I think so Brian because you're right
you know DNA and fingerprints and all
those things bring a lot of tangibility
to a jury in terms of deciding whether
to convict someone of the a crime which
they're charged we have to keep in mind
though that this is a little bit
different Arena not just in the Civil
sense but we're talking about damages
right so one thing one step that the
depth team had to do is prove that he
was defamed right so if they have proven
that by through his testimony or some of
the other witnesses that Terry
referenced then the question becomes
what are the damages what kind of
tangibility can be placed on that in
order to make a jury feel comfortable
with the figure and I think this witness
did that it brought it forward and said
okay this is a damage as well it's not
perfectly tangible it gives a jury
enough to feel comfortable rendering a
verdict of 50 million dollars which is
going to be something that people might
not be able to wrap their heads around
but it gives this jury enough in order
to deliver that into the courtroom yeah
I think our producers actually said it
the best she said it's something that
the jury can really sink their teeth
into and I think it gives them something
tangible to really think about we'll see
how they end up deciding this case as it
continues thank you both to keep up with
the capital gavel coverage of the Johnny
Depp versus Amber Heard trial make sure
to follow our newest podcast lawn crime
sidebar listen in as law and crimes top
hosts recap the highs and lows of the
trial so far straight from the Fairfax
County Courthouse in Virginia subscribe
on Apple podcast or online at
lawncrime.com
when we come back a shocking Revelation
straight from the Supreme Court of the
United States what leaked documents have
to say about the Roe v Wade skoda's
ruling
[Music]
welcome back a days long Manhunt for an
Alabama corrections officer who
officials believe helped the inmate
escape is still ongoing Casey white was
serving as 75-year sentence and awaiting
a capital murder trial when he and the
assistant director of Corrections at the
Lauderdale County Detention Center went
missing Friday Vicky white is now facing
charges the two are not related
officials shared a video showing Vicki
driving when she was last seen Friday
taking Casey who was Shackled in her
patrol car for a mental health
evaluation at the County's courthouse
authorities believe she was acting of
her own free will a big obstacle for law
enforcement now is that they don't know
what vehicle the two are driving after
her patrol car was found abandoned and
there is no clear motive as to why she
would have done this in a statement the
county sheriff says Vicki's co-workers
and other County officials have the
utmost respect for her the sheriff says
for months she had talked about retiring
and had even submitted her retirement
papers just days before the two
disappear weird
and the Supreme Court is expected to
strike down Roe v Wade according to
Elite's draft of an opinion repealing
The Landmark decision now Democratic
senators are responding calling for
legislation to codify abortion access
into law
if passed the initial draft majority
opinion written by Justice Samuel Alito
would be the end to the federal
constitutional protection of abortion
rights and a seceding 1992 decision of
Planned Parenthood versus Casey in the
document Justice Alito writes Rowan
Casey must be overruled and that the
issue of abortion should be returned to
quote the people's elected
representatives it would allow for each
state to decide on restricting or
Banning abortions after hearing oral
arguments four of the other Republican
appointed justices voted with Alito in
December the leak of the draft is a rare
breach of skoda secure secrecy and
tradition surrounding its deliberations
on Tuesday Senators on both sides spoke
out about the disclosed opinion foreign
now that the court is poised to strike
down Roe it is my intention for the
Senate to hold a vote on legislation to
codify the right to an abortion in law a
vote on this legislation is not an
abstract exercise this is as urgent and
real as it gets never before in modern
history has an internal draft been
leaked to the public
while the justices were still
deciding a case
never before
whoever committed this Lawless Act
knew exactly
what it could bring about
the justices already require security
is expected to issue a decision in the
next couple of months
Kirk chief justice Roberts has confirmed
this draft is real so we could see uh
Roe v Wade being overturned what do you
think of alito's argument that abortions
are not a liberty quote unquote under
the 14th Amendment
I think it fails to recognize the fact
that it has been a liberty under the
14th Amendment for nearly 50 years now
it has become one of those inherent
Liberties that we have enjoyed in most
of our lifetimes so and he wants to kick
it back to being a morality issue which
could really evidence a big sea change
in many different cases reproductive
Freedom uh marital Freedom all those
sort of things so it's very a very big
sea change is coming if this opinion
comes out as it is
yeah I know some people have been been a
bit alarm in this but what about
Virginia the U.S and other marital
issues as well that uh so many people
are affected by Terry if this ruling
goes through what does it mean for
abortion rights in the United States as
a whole and blue States versus red
States
well you know Kirk mentioned the C wave
and that's exactly what will happen we
already know that there are trigger laws
in place in approximately 20 or so
states where if this ruling comes down
and there's no reason to think it won't
then we'll have laws that will either
ban or severely restrict abortions and
so I think that we're going to see women
in particular looking to go to other
states where they will have more
Liberties and so there'll be some Forum
shopping and I think that's a shame I
think that this is one of those
unenumerated rights in the Constitution
that should be upheld as precedent yeah
I mean there's clear myself loving
Deborah James the case I was talking
about well thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on Law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]